whether you want to watch the premiere
of Westworld or get caught up on Game of
Thrones you can only do it with HBO and
now you have more options for watching
on ps4 or ps3 I'm Tony and this is your
premium game spot news update the HBO
now app has launched on ps4 and ps3
alongside HBO and Cinemax support and
PlayStation View you can now subscribe
to those channels independently for 15
bucks a month and every HBO subscription
gets you into HBO now alternatively you
can sign up for playstation views new
Ultra plan 65 bucks a month or 75 if you
live in certain cities get you both HBO
and Cinemax Plus over a hundred
additional channels so if you're looking
to turn your ps4 ps3 into an all in one
media device now you have some more
options
PlayStation View offers other
subscription tiers ranging from thirty
to fifty five dollars you can find all
the details on Sony's official site if
you want to keep up with all the latest
from HBO head on over to GameSpot sister
channel GameSpot universe and for all
the biggest playstation news you're
already in the right place